i saw the video of joe reviewing tick
tocks user terms it's it's crazy um
there's a clip out there somewhere on
youtube it's not very long you can go
look it up but he's but it's but it's
basically like here let me see if i can
dig it up real quick it's not a very
long clip
uh joe rogan
exposes tick
tick tock i always spell that wrong
in terms of
see if the search engine works
crazy terms of service
yeah here we go
uh yeah you guys got to watch this it's
like it's like a two minute clip
share screen tab
joe rogan there we go
oh my god i read
tick tock's terms of service i went down
a tick tock rabbit hole yesterday yeah
it's good i stayed home smoked a little
weed and i started reading up on tick
tock yeah oh my god i'm going to read
you this because this is so crazy
imagine being a standout comic and be
like i'm going to smoke a blunt and go
read some tick tock terms of service
is it good or bad bad it's so what are
you saying it's a bad place to be listen
to this this is uh from tick tocks
privacy policy all right it said we
collect certain information about the
device you use to access the platform
such as your ip address um
user region
this is this is really crazy uh user
agent mobile carrier time zone settings
i identifiers for advertising purpose
model of your device we're only we're
only a third of the way through and they
already know the model of your device
everything about your phone
uh you know your operating system here
i'm gonna speed it up a little bit
it's the device system network type
device ids your screen resolution your
screen resolution like they're
collecting data on your screen
resolution rating system app and file
names and types so all your apps and all
your file names so you know about all
your file names on your phone all the
apps you have on your phone all the
things you have filed away on your phone
they have access to that file names and
types keystroke patterns or rhythms so
they're monitoring your keystrokes which
means they know every
if you guys don't know about heat
mapping um if if you've ever created a
website one of the things that you want
to do with a website is you want to put
this this like cookie code on it
basically and it tracks uh heat mapping
so what you do on the screen um
this is basically what tick tock's doing
is they're essentially heat mapping the
use of their app and i'm assuming um
since they're tracking other apps and
what you're doing with your phone
everything pretty much
[ __ ] thing you type wow battery state
uh audio setup the percentage of your
battery audio settings things and
connected audio devices where you log in
from multiple devices you will be able
to use your profile information to
identify your activity across devices we
may also associate you with information
collected from devices other than those
you you use to log into the platform
we're only halfway through
meaning they can use other computers
that you're not even using to log into
tick tock they can suck the data off
that that's what you're agreeing to when
you download and start using tick tock
that's wild it's insane dude like here
i'm gonna remove this now
i i have a tick tock account you know
and i upload clips there and i'm telling
you right now delete tick tock you don't
need it
um
i'm telling you as somebody that uploads
video there i don't like i really try
not to consume it because if you start
scrolling through it it's like they suck
you in man with their with their total
[ __ ] hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you